الى كوسوفو التي تشهد ارتفاعا في منسوب
التوتر الذي يلازمها منذ فيصالها عن صربي
اواخر التسعينيه
حرب اوكرانيا انطلقت مع قرار السلطات
بريشتينا ارسال تعزيزات امنيه الى المناطق
التي كان من المقرر ان تجرى فيها انتخابات
بعد ايام خطوه بريشتين هذه اثار الغضب
السلطات المحليه التي تتمتع بهامش واسع من
الحكم الذاتي وانتقادات في صربي المجاوره
التي لا تزال تعتبر كتب جزءا من اراضيها
المبكره التي كان من المقررين ان تجري في
ال 18 ديسمبر كانون الاول اجلت الى ربيع
العام الجديد لكن التوتر في المنطقه
مكاننا
مسؤولو سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جزء البوريل قال ان الاتحاد لم
يتسامح مع نجمات على ضباط بعثته المدنيه
في شمالكس
اخر الاخبار
على استعداد لوقف التصعيد وانا ادعوهم الى
ذلك بشيده
الولايات المتحده الى ضبط النفس واتخاذ
اجراءات فوريه لتهدئه الموقف والامتناع عن
اي اعمال استفزازيه
عثماني في العاصمه بريشتينا شمال